Lord Shiva. You've seen the image. Third
eye, cobra around his neck, sitting in
stillness while the world burns. But
here's the thing. Shiva isn't just
another god in a long list of deities.
He is the end of the line. The one who
shows up when everything else stops
working. He doesn't rule from a throne
or a fancy palace. He chills in the
mountains, smeared in ash while
meditating through the chaos. But if you
think that makes him peaceful, you're
dead wrong. Shiva is the god of
destruction. Not rage, not revenge, just
pure raw reset. He tears everything down
so something new can begin. And somehow
he's also the most loved. People don't
just fear him, they follow him because
deep down we all know sometimes things
have to fall apart before they can make
sense. So Shiva isn't just a figure from
old stories. He might be the most
relevant god you've never really looked
at until today. So let's dive in.
[Music]
What's up people and welcome back to
Religion Camp. My name is Mark Gagnon
and thank you for joining me in my tent
where every single Sunday we explore the
most interesting, fascinating,
controversial stories from every
religion from around the world from all
time. I'm joined by my dear friend Gabe.
Gabe, what's up? What's going on? All
right. All right. So guys, today we have
a fascinating topic to dive into. I
myself did not grow up Hindu. I didn't
know very many practi practicing Hindus
growing up. But I become fascinated by
this worldview. I refrain from calling
it a religion because I understand that
it's more of a philosophy, a way of
life, a study of consciousness that is
wrapped up into one of the oldest forms
of organized religious literature ever.
And for that reason, I'm both fascinated
but also a novice in the area. So if
there are any Hindus watching or
listening, please feel free to comment
if there's anything that I may have
missed. But today we're jumping in to
the story and the philosophy of Lord
Shiva. Shiva is is a fascinating deity,
right? I mean it's basically every
contradiction that you could imagine all
rolled into a divine being, right? This
is a deity who destroys everything but
is also the one creating it. uh the
hermit who wants nothing to do with the
world but is passionately and
desperately in love with it. This silent
meditator whose every dance steps to
keep the entire universe spinning
through stories that have been whispered
and sung for thousands of years. Shiva
emerges not just as a god people pray
to, but as this incredible mirror that
shows you the deepest truths about what
it even means to exist. So let's start
at the beginning. The divine paradox. So
forget everything you know about gods or
religion or anything like that for a
second. Okay? Shiva isn't sitting on
some golden throne somewhere in heaven
judging your life choices. He's
something more mysterious and mystical
than that. So there's this idea in some
versions of Hinduism that effectively is
a Hindu trinity. Right? Right? So you
have Brahma that creates the universe
and Vishnu who keeps things running
smoothly and Shiva who ends things. But
here's where you need to completely flip
your understanding. When we say Shiva is
the destroyer, we're not talking about
some cosmic super villain that destroys
things for fun. I mean, have you ever
seen like a forest fire? It's
devastating, right? It's raw and
unforgiving and absolute. Everything in
its path will be destroyed. But then
here is the divine profound truth. From
the very ashes of a fire, new life
begins. Not just as a return, but like a
resurgence, stronger, more vibrant, and
more alive than the forest was before.
And that is the essence of Shiva. He's
the force that destroys not out of
malice, but out of necessity, to clear
what no longer serves, so that something
greater, something more essential can
rise in its place. But here's what's
really wild about him. He appears in
these ancient texts not as like a
one-dimensional character, but as this
walking, breathing contradiction at
times that somehow makes perfect sense.
He's Ady Yogi, the very first yogi
sitting in complete stillness high up in
the Himalayas. But he's also this
devoted husband to Parvati and a loving
father to Ganesha. keys Nataraja whose
cosmic dance literally creates,
maintains, and destroys the universe in
one continuous flow. And somehow he's
also this silent teacher who can
communicate wisdom without really saying
a single word. You might think of like
the the yin and yang from Taoism, but
Shiva takes this balance to a different
level. He simultaneously is outside the
world but deeply within. It is
terrifying but also completely
passionate and loving of humanity.
Completely wild and erratic but
extremely wise and detached but capable
of love. And here's what's incredible.
These aren't just dusty old stories in
you know old vadic books. Right now as
you're reading these words millions of
people across India and a matter of fact
across the world are starting their
their day with the phrase om nama shaya.
This is a sacred sound that honors
Shiva's presence in their life. And I
apologize for my pronunciation. I'm sure
that I'm not hitting that correctly. But
for many Hindus listening, you'll know
what I mean. Pilgrims are literally
climbing dangerous mountain paths to
reach a natural ice formation at
Amarnath Cave, risking everything just
to glimpse what they believe could be
Shiva's presence. Families are
gathering, staying awake all night in
devotion. In India's dance performances,
you'll see dancers embodying Shiva's
cosmic dance with movements that have
been passed down through generations
like like almost like a family heirloom.
And those uh bronze nataraja statues
that you'll see in in different Hindu
temples, they're not just museum pieces.
They're this living focal point where
people offer, you know, flowers and uh
lamps and candles and pour water while
chanting hymns that are older than most
modern civilizations. Even in modern
cities like Mumbai and Delhi, tech
workers and business executives will
pause during their lunch break to visit
Shiva temples. They're seeking a
centered stillness that Shiva represents
before diving back into, you know, their
crazy fast-paced lives. It's like having
almost like a cosmic reset button right
in the middle of urban chaos. And this
living dimension matters because it
reminds you that Shiva's teachings
aren't just philosophical ideas floating
around. They are a practical wisdom that
still helps many Hindus around the world
navigate birth and death and success and
failure, love and loss just like they
have for thousands of years. So let me
tell you about one of the most
fascinating stories in all of Hinduism.
A tale that really establishes who Shiva
is and you know how Shiva plays into the
cosmic hierarchy. So you have Brahma the
creator of the entire universe and
Vishnu the protector and the preserver
and they're having this heated argument
about who's most powerful and Brahma is
basically like look I created everything
so obviously I'm the greatest. and
vision fires back but I protect and I
maintain everything without me the
universe will just collapse you can make
but you can't preserve and that makes me
the most important and as their argument
gets more and more intense suddenly this
third presence manifests but this isn't
your typical divine presence Shiva shows
up as this cosmic column of of just pure
light and we're not talking about you
know just bright light here imagine
light so infinite that it stretches
beyond the heavens and deep into the
earth with no beginning or end. It's
like a radiance that makes you forget
what darkness even means. Then Shiva
throws down this challenge. Find the top
or bottom of this pillar if you can. And
what follows is this epic quest that's
it's almost comical in how impossible it
is. Brahma transforms into a swan and
flies upwards trying to seek the top and
Vishnu becomes this boar that digs deep
into the earth searching for the bottom.
And these are divine beings that we're
talking about. They search for ages,
literally eons, using every ounce of
their cosmic power, but they could find
no end. And here's where it gets
interesting. Brahma, exhausted and sort
of embarrassed, makes a crucial mistake.
Instead of just admitting that he
couldn't get to the end of the pillar of
light, he conspires with a fallen kitaki
flower to lie about reaching the top.
And this is a big mistake. When Shiva
emerges from the pillar, he immediately
exposes the deception. The punishment is
swift and meaningful. Brahma is cursed
as he wouldn't be widely worshiped on
earth. And the Kataki flower was forever
banned from Shiva's worship. But here's
the deeper truth that transforms this
from just like a cool ancient story into
really profound wisdom. Shiva didn't
prove his greatness through competition
or force. He demonstrated that true
divinity transcends the whole game of
creator verse protector. And that
infinite pillar, I mean, it represents
the formless, limitless reality from
which all things emerge into which
everything returns. Sort of
consciousness in and of itself. And this
is why the the lingam, often completely
misunderstood in the west, just as
almost a a phallic symbol of sorts,
carries a really profound meaning. It
represents a formless absolute just
eternal presence beyond all creation.
You could think of it, I guess, of, you
know, how Christians might think of uh
God the Father, just infinite. All
things stem uh from God. It's a similar
concept. And it's pointing to pure
consciousness that supports everything
you can see, touch, and imagine. And so
now that we have sort of an
understanding of Shiva's cosmic
significance, let's dive into how this
transcendent reality becomes visible. So
in Hinduism, gods aren't just imagined
through stories. They're seen and felt
and understood in their visual forms.
And Shiva, he speaks through what you
might call sort of a like a visual
theology. Every aspect of his appearance
tells a story not just about him but
about the cosmos and your mind and the
path to uh spiritual freedom to mti. So
let's start with these uh magnificent
locks the jata. These immediately mark
him as the supreme yogi someone who has
completely renounced worldly attachments
and mastered the wild forces of nature.
And these aren't just symbolic. They
play a starring role in one of India's
most beloved myths. Picture this cosmic
drama. When the sacred Ganji's river
prepared to fall to Earth, its force was
so immense that it could have just
shattered the entire planet. So think
about that for a second, right? A river
so powerful it just could destroy the
world. Only Shiva had the power to
receive it safely. So what does he do?
He positions himself to catch this
devastating torrent in his hair,
trapping its force and slowly releasing
it as this gentle life-giving stream.
Suddenly, these sort of locks that Shiva
has become way more than just a symbol
of renunciation. They transform into
this divine compassion and cosmic
control. And this is what I mean when I
say that the physical manifestation of
these deities reflects some type of
spiritual balance. Every time you see
Shiva, you're looking at the story of
how destruction is transformed into
life. And if you look even closer at his
forehead where this crescent moon glows
softly in his hair. In Hindu philosophy,
the moon represents time and sort of the
restless mind. It's always changing,
waxing, waning, just like life's sort of
cycles of birth and growth and decline
and renewal. And so by wearing the moon,
Shiva is showing his mastery over time
and that fluctuating mind of ours. He
exists beyond the ticking clock, beyond
emotions and thoughts. It's like he's
reminding you that true wisdom means
mastering your internal consciousness
rather than being mastered by it. But
perhaps the most powerful symbol in his
third eye, it's positioned right in the
center of the forehead, and it's not
decorative. This is a gateway to inner
visions, a higher consciousness, a
spiritual truth that cuts through all
the illusions of reality. What's up,
guys? We're going to take a quick break
because I have great news. Religion Camp
has merch. That's right. We have amazing
t-shirts like this one you see here and
this one. We got hats, all sorts of very
interesting designs, not only for
Christianity, the one I was raised in,
but for all religions, Hinduism, Sikism,
Islam, Judaism, Mormonism. I actually
don't know if we have a Mormonism shirt,
but maybe we we can we can work on that
if we don't even, you know, Latter-day
Saints trying to cop. Anyway, you can
catch it all here at this link. We'll
also have it in the description as well
as the comments. Get that right now and
peace be with you. What's up, guys?
We're going to take a break really quick
because you are a grown child. Yes,
you're a giant manchild and you just
love stuff in your face and all the
sugary cereals you ate when you were a
kid. When you were just a fat little
8-year-old, you would sit down on your
couch and you would just eat these these
sugary cereals. And nowadays, you try to
do that like I have, you feel terrible.
You go, "Oh, yeah, my blood pressure is
rising. I do get a hangover from eating
these cereals that I ate when I was a
child." And that's why I want to talk to
you about Magic Spoon. This thing right
here, freshly opened because I was just
engorging myself. Magic Spoon is all the
flavors that you love that come from
your favorite nostalgic cereals. Flavors
like fruity, cocoa, frosted. Do those
sound familiar to you? Because legally I
can't say what they are, but those are
the flavors that Magic Spoon has. And
here's what's amazing about Magic Spoon.
It's the same taste. It's all the flavor
packed into every bite from those
childhood cereals. But 13 grams of
protein, zero grams of sugar, and four
grams of net carbs. Yeah, imagine that.
13 grams of protein. This is protein
packed cereal. So instead of being a
little fat kid, you can sit down on
Sunday morning watching cartoons and get
freaking jacked. Yeah, you'll look like
Ronnie Coleman or something. You keep on
crushing these, you're going to be
diesel as hell. So instead of being a
little fat boy, you can be a giant
strong man, but still keep your same
habits of just sitting down and watching
your cartoons. And for the listeners of
this program, if you go to
magixpoon.com/camp,
that's right, magixpoon.com/cam,
you're going to get $5 off your next
order. Five whole dollars that you can
save and apply to therapy for figuring
out your disgusting twisted childhood of
stuffing your face with processed sugars
and red dye 40 and stuff like that. But
with Magic Spoon, you don't have to
worry about any of that stuff. It's all
good. 13 g of protein, none of the
sugar, 4 g of carbs. Get it today. Magic
Spoon on Amazon or at your nearest
grocery store. Or you can go to
magixpoon.com/campc
for $5 off. And let's get back to the
show, you fatty. And the story that
explains this is is really incredible. I
mean, once Kamadeva, the god of desire,
decided to mess with the meditating
Shiva by shooting him with love's
arrows. Shiva is you know in this deep
contemplative state and then all of a
sudden he's being hit with you know
literal like Cupid's bows right and
disturbed from his meditation Shiva
opens his third eye in anger and
instantly Kamadeva is reduced to ashes
gone the message here isn't that love is
evil but that uncontrolled desire blinds
you to a deeper reality that third eye
burns away illusions an ego allowing you
to perceive the truth beneath the
appearance. It represents the awakened
consciousness that sees beyond the
surface of reality, beyond the games
that your mind and your emotions play on
you. And around Shiva's neck coils the
vasuki, the serpent king. And this
carries a ton of layers of meaning.
Unlike western traditions where serpents
are often, you know, symbolized as evil,
as you know, you think of the garden of
Eden when a serpent, you know, tempts
Eve. In Hindu philosophy, it's often
associated with time and cosmic energy
and protective power. So the vasuki that
is around the neck actually helped churn
the ocean during creation. And when
deadly poison emerged from that
churning, threatening all existence,
both the serpent and Shiva became
protectors. The snake's three coils
around the neck, they represent the
past, the present, and the future. Time
itself under this divine control. And
like a snake shedding its skin, this
symbol reminds you that spiritual growth
often requires painful transformation
and renewal. Finally, there's the ash
that covers Shiva's body, the vipruti.
This isn't mourning paint or like a
death symbol. After his beloved wife
Sati died in a cosmic protest, Shiva
withdrew from the world in grief and it
just overwhelmed him covering himself
with the ashes of her funeral p. But in
this act, he also demonstrated ultimate
detachment. So you see, Ash represents
what remains when all illusion burns
away. the final truth that everything
worldly is just temporary and the only
eternal spirit is what endures. It's
beautiful and heartbreaking kind of at
the same time. It's this contradiction
that we're talking about. And the tiger
skin that he wears or often is seen
sitting upon that symbolizes the mastery
over primal instinct and triumph over
this material world. you know, sort of
shedding the carnal desires of the
animal that's sort of within humankind
and instead focusing on consciousness
and what truly makes us human. And it
sort of reflects both a power but also a
connection to nature's raw forces. And
together, these symbols create more than
just, you know, a picture. They form a
spiritual map pointing towards this
deeper understanding of life and the
universe and what it truly means to be
awakened. No exploration of Shiva would
be complete without understanding his
most dynamic form. Nataraja, the lord of
the dance. Picture this. Shiva encircled
by flames performing the ananda tandeva,
the dance of bliss. And this isn't
entertainment. This is the fundamental
rhythm of existence in and of itself.
That through this dance that you know
all things actually exist. And if you
see the images of Shiva, you can
understand what I'm saying. In this
choreography, Shiva is performing five
essential acts simultaneously. There's
creation, preservation, destruction, the
veiling of truth through illusion, and
liberation from said illusion. Each
gesture carries profound meaning that
speaks to both cosmic and personal
transformation. I mean, look at the
hands. One holds the damu, this small
drum whose beats represent the
primordial existence of creation. the
very vibration from which all existence
emerges. That's basically the heartbeat
of the universe. And another hand holds
flame signaling destruction and renewal.
Not as an ending, but as this necessary
transition. It's like watching someone
tend a sacred fire that never goes out.
It just changes and transforms. One hand
forms the Apaya mudra, offering
protection and fearlessness to all
beings. And the fourth, it points
gracefully to his raised foot
symbolizing moka, the liberation that
lifts your soul beyond the suffering.
And beneath his other foot lies apasara,
the demon of ignorance and the ego. But
what's brilliant is notice that Shiva
doesn't destroy this demon. He just
subdues it because there's no
destruction of ignorance and the ego.
There's just control. He's teaching that
ego must be transcended, not
annihilated. You need your ego to
function in the world, but you can't be
enslaved by it. And here's something
that I found fascinating. When you
really look at Nataraja's form, every
curve and angle of his body creates this
geometric pattern, particularly of the
the hexog or the satona. It's like the
ancient sculptors of this faith or
philosophy knew something about
mathematics that we're just sort of now
rediscovering. His dance isn't wild
chaos. It's precisely choreographed in
existence reflecting again this balance
of masculine and feminine. When you see
the image for Hindus, they're witnessing
the universe in motion. They see every
galaxy spinning, every heart beating,
every thought arising and dissolving,
all participating in Shiva's eternal
dance. And for Hindus, we're all
participating in it right now, whether
you realize it or not. Now, let's travel
to Mount Kaash, rising majestically from
the Tibetan plateau. And this isn't
just, you know, Shiva's mythical
address. It's a symbol of inner peace in
the highest state of human awareness.
Multiple traditions honor this place
because it represents where the spirit
and matter converge where people you
practitioners and pilgrims can identify
and discover the true self. As Ady Yogi,
the first yogi, Shiva embodies the
transformative power of focused
awareness to transcend ego and illusion.
And in yogic tradition, he shares this
sacred wisdom with the saparishies, the
seven great sages revered for their
profound connection with the divine. And
this establishes yoga not as this human
invention, but as a divine revelation
passed down from the gods to people. And
here's what makes Shiva's meditation
really important to the Hindus and the
Shivites that sort of follow this
philosophy. Unlike withdrawal from
worldly engagement, he demonstrates
awareness while remaining active. He
doesn't escape reality. He's fully
present even in the deepest state of
spiritual unity. Shiva continues
managing the universe's operation. And
this reveals the ultimate spiritual
idea, enlightenment in and of itself.
Finding that still centered place within
yourself while remaining engaged with
everything around you. Think of it as
being calm in the center of, you know, a
spinning wheel. Peaceful on the inside,
dynamic on the outside. And it's not
about running away from life. It's about
being so centered that life can't knock
you off balance no matter what happens.
And the followers and the meditators of
Shiva on Mount Kalesh teach you that
true liberation isn't an escape from
life, but integration within it. And a
key insight here is, you know, remaining
unshaken by chaos while being completely
engaged in the world. It's not just
about disconnection and, you know,
moving off to be a hermit somewhere. And
it's not about being constantly in the
rat race. It's about being dynamic on
the outside, but at peace in the middle.
And it's a very difficult and profound
integration. I mean, detached but not
disconnected, present, but not
possessive.
really for many Hindus the freedom comes
from being fully in the world but not
being owned by it which matter of fact I
mean that is a Christian ideal right to
be in the world but not of it and this
exists within you know the uh the the
the Shivite followers in Hinduism and
here's where Shiva's role as a protector
takes on a different dimension in
western traditions gods or you know God
himself acts as a ruler and a savior
from above but in Hindu philosophy
There's this idea that divinity is sort
of a participation in struggle that
protecting life not through domination
but sort of through like a personal
sacrifice. So this brings us to the
story of Samudra Manthan the churning of
the cosmic ocean that we mentioned
before and this is this sort of sweeping
drama this story where Shiva plays the
unexpected role of a universal healer.
So picture this negotiation, okay? You
have gods and demons, also known as
assuras, who usually can't stand each
other, you know, but suddenly they're
shaking hands. They're at peace. And
why? It's because they both want the
same thing. They want amit, which is the
immortality, the this sort of, you know,
this eternal force that's hidden in this
primordial ocean. In order to retrieve
it, they use Mount Mandara as this
churning rod and Vasuki, the serpent
king that we mentioned before, as a
rope. And this wasn't simple mixing.
They're stirring the very fabric of
reality. So, you can imagine the power
that it takes to create all things that
have ever existed, ever. And before this
nectar of immortality appears, something
deadly emerges first. This poison so
potent that it threatens all existence.
This halah hala we're talking about a
toxicity so extreme that the fumes begin
to kill every living being in the
universe. I mean everything from gods,
demons, humans, animals, everything is
facing annihilation and all things
created are on the brink of collapse and
neither the gods or the demons despite
all their controlled power could stop
the catastrophe. All existence faced the
end. So they turn to Shiva, the one who
exists simultaneously on society's edge
and at the cosmos's center. He embodies
both the outer who renounces
conventional power and the divine lord
who transcends it. This makes him
perfect for the crisis. So what does
Shiva do? Without a moment's hesitation,
he steps forward and performs the
unthinkable. He drinks the poison to
save the world. But here's what's
incredible. He doesn't swallow it
completely. Instead, he holds it in his
throat. balancing the deadly force
without letting it harm himself or
creation. And his throat turns this deep
blue from the act, earning him the name
Nilanta, the bluethroated one. And this
reveals Shiva's true nature, not as a
god of destruction, as it's often seen
in the west, but as this divine being
who absorbs the universal suffering to
protect existence. And his power doesn't
destroy for chaos, but transforms for
protection to keep the universe in
balance. That poison held in his throat
demonstrates that even life's most toxic
elements must be or can be contained and
neutralized. Not through force or
aggression, but through an inner
strength and a compassion and a desire
to achieve balance. And the wisdom here
for human beings is really interesting.
Just as Shiva contained this poison, you
face your own emotional and spiritual
toxins, right? I mean, anger and ego and
jealousy and grief. And it kind of just
shows that true strength isn't escaping
these emotions, but learning to hold
them in and to transform them. Just like
Shiva's blue throat, you too can contain
your inner toxicity without letting it
poison yourself and other people as it's
told within Hindu philosophy. What's up
people? Quick announcement. If you are a
fan of Camp Gagnon or Religion Camp, I
have great news because we are dropping
history camp. That's right. This is the
channel where we're going to be
exploring the most interesting,
fascinating, controversial topics from
all time throughout all history. Right?
You probably know about Benjamin
Franklin, uh I don't know, Thomas
Jefferson, Nicola Tesla, interesting
figures from history. And you probably
learned about school and they were
pretty boring, but not here. No, as you
know, uh I was raised by a conspiracy
theorist. So, I'm going to be diving
deep into all of the interesting,
strange, occult, and secretive societal
relationships that all of these famous,
influential men from our shared past
have. So, if you're interested, please
go ahead and subscribe to the YouTube
channel. It will be pinned in the
description as well as the comments. And
if you're on Spotify, this doesn't
really apply to you, but these episodes
will be dropping as well. Just go ahead
and give us a high rating because it
really helps the show. Alrighty, don't
skip forward, guys, because I am on the
road. World's fastest ad read coming at
you. I'm going to be in Portland,
Oregon, Fort Worth, Texas, Austin,
Texas, Stanford, Philly, Levittown,
Chandler, Arizona, San Diego. I'm also
going to be adding Toronto, Montreal, as
well as Washington DC, and a bunch of
other dates. You can get all that at the
markagnon.com. Dates are in the
description also in probably the
comments of this episode. Go see me on
the road. Come hang out. I'll be hanging
out with everyone after the show. Come
shake my hand. Call me an idiot.
Whatever you want to do, I will be
there. Uh, additionally, I will be doing
my one hour of standup comedy. I'm very
proud of this hour. I'm really excited
to share with you guys, and it would
mean the world if everyone could come on
out. And what do you wear to a show on
the road? That's a great question. You
can go to campgoods.co. That's right. We
got merch. We got camp merch. We got
hats, hoodies, t-shirts. A lot of stuff
is out of stock. Things have been
selling like hotcakes, but we're going
to be restocking everything in all the
sizes. So, you can go there right now,
get all the merch, get all the coolest
clothing in the podcast game. We're
going to be updating that site
regularly. And if you come out to a
show, I'd love to see you sporting some
of the threads that we got up online. I
will see you guys there. Let's get back
to the show. And like with much of Hindu
mythology, there is always a romantic
element. And this is the story of Lord
Shiva, Deviati, and Devi Parvati. And
this isn't just a romance. This is again
some a cosmic play exploring how divine
love and loss and reunion keeps the
balance. The story itself begins with
Devisati, the daughter of Dakshia,
making a choice that would shake the
cosmos. She decides to marry Lord Shiva.
Now, picture the family drama here,
okay? Her father sees Shiva as unworthy,
this unconventional hermit who uh sort
of rejected these orthodox rituals and
expectations. Absolutely not husband
material in Dsha's eyes. But Sati and
her devotion transcended family
expectations and conventions. Their
marriage represented this eternal clash
between patriarchal ritual authority and
Shiva's transformative
transcendent principle. Love that defies
convention, choosing spiritual strength
over approval. And the crisis explodes
when Dakshia organizes this grand yajna,
a fire ritual, and deliberately excludes
Shiva. And this isn't just being rude.
It was an assault on Shiva's divine
dignity. And against Shiva's advice,
Sati attended out of family obligation
and sort of a, you know, a divine
intuition, if you will. And instead of
finding respect or understanding, she
encountered only contempt. Her father's
arrogance uh basically rejects the one
that she loves the most. And what should
have been a family gathering becomes
this humiliation of her husband. Imagine
someone that you love is now
disrespected like that, right?
Overwhelmed by outrage, Sati uses her
yogic powers to emulate herself,
literally to put herself on fire, a a
sacred fire, so to speak. And her
self-sacrifice becomes both cosmic
protest and spiritual statement. When
devotion is dishonored and love is
scorned, even the divine feminine
reaches this breaking point. And this is
something that occurs through a lot of
Hindu mythology that you have uh the
sort of larger story that occurs in the
cosmos that then human beings can pull a
practical wisdom from. So what happens
next? Shiva's grief explodes into a
catastrophe. He's so overwhelmed with
sorrow over his wife's death that now he
manifests as Verabhadra, this warrior
who beheaded Dakshia and destroys the
entire ritual. But that wasn't the end.
Shiva then performed the Rudra Tandava.
And this is again another dance of
destruction that it threatens the
collapse of the entire universe. Even
creation trembled before the force of
losing someone that you love. Shiva
holds Sati's charred body wandering the
universe in anguish that you know
basically threatens the entire
universe's existence. And his grief is
so profound that he was literally
tearing reality apart. So to restore
balance, Vishnu intervenes and using a
specific chakra, a a weaponized chakra,
he dismembers Sati's body. Each fragment
that falls to earth sanctifies the land
with a divine presence, creating the 51
shakti pithas. And these are sacred
sites where the goddess's energy remains
eternally alive. And matter of fact,
these holy places span from India uh all
the way to, you know, the south of the
continent, transforming the entire
subcontinent into a sacred landscape of
feminine power. And what begins as this
loss becomes now an eternal blessing.
Grief transformed into points of divine
connection. And from this cosmic trauma,
Shiva retreated into meditation that was
both personal mourning but also
metaphysical. His withdrawal represented
this re-emersion into the formless void
transforming him into this primordial
yogi. Right? This first yogi that we
talked about whose stillness becomes a
foundation for all spiritual
disciplines. But here's the thing about
life and the universe itself is that it
cannot function without the reunion of
consciousness, right? Without this
reunion of of Shiva and Shakti. Deviati
returned as Devi Parvati, the daughter
of the Himalayas, signaling the divine
feminine's return to create this cosmic
equilibrium and drawing Shiva back into
creative engagement. Devi Parvati's
quest isn't just personal. It was the
universe's need to heal the separation
between this, you know, transcendent
awareness and the regular present active
engagement that all people should be
going through. So throughout intense
austerities in the Himalayas, you know,
fasting, meditation and harsh elements,
she demonstrates that love itself can be
a spiritual discipline capable of
awakening even the most withdrawn person
or consciousness. And their eventual
reunion represents the convergence of
purusha. This pure consciousness with a
creative energy known as pakriti. A
metaphysical fusion of which all life
emerges. Shiva tested Parvati through
various disguises before accepting her
ultimate devotion ensuring that her
commitment was absolute and eternal.
Their wedding was a cosmic necessity.
Again, the universe is in disarray
because of the loss, but now it requires
the reunion. So, Parvati's presence
transforms Shiva from this sort of aloof
aesthetic hermit to once again an
engaged householder.
As mother to Ganesha and Cartaya, she
anchors him in life cycles of birth and
protection and love. And what was once a
tragedy now becomes a blessing and the
creation of the universe as we know it.
From this divine union comes one of the
most profound elements of Hinduism and
you know one of the most heartbreaking
stories the birth and the beheading of
Lord Ganesha. Shiva was often away
meditating or wandering uh leaving Devi
Parvati lonely and logging for
companionship. So within the story of
the the Hindu myth, wanting privacy
while bathing, she shaped a boy from
clay of her own body, her creation, her
guardian, her son known as Lord Ganesha,
instructing him to guard the entrance.
The fatal encounter arrived when Shiva
returns unaware of this new creation and
Lord Ganesha, loyal to his mother's
command, refuses to let this stranger
enter, not knowing that this is the
husband of Parvati. And so Shiva,
enraged and not recognizing his own son,
severs his boy's head. Imagine the
horror of that moment, right? What
begins as a mother's simple desire for
privacy becomes a family tragedy. A
father unknowingly kills his own son. So
once again, we're now faced with another
cosmic tragedy. Devi Parvati's grief
over the loss of her son isn't just
personal. It's like this cosmic show.
Her sorrow awakens Mahakali and fierce
protective forces ready to tear the
world apart once again. And this wasn't
just a mother mourning. It was life
itself crying out against a violation.
Her fury reminded all existence that
Shaki is both gentle and a nurturer, but
also a fierce protector. And when life
is disrespected and love is violated,
she possesses the power to destroy what
she once created. So to restore balance
and calm Parvati's cosmic anguish, Shiva
commanded his followers to retrieve the
head of the first living being they
encountered facing north. And they
encountered an elephant. This choice
wasn't random. The elephant's head
embodied Buddhi, this divine wisdom and
the power to remove obstacles,
transforming the resurrected child into
Ganesha, Lord of thresholds and
beginnings and transitions. And if you
see an image of Lord Ganesha, you will
see where this elephant head has its
sacred symbolic importance. This divine
intervention becomes more than grief
solution. It's again cosmic negotiation,
reconciling Parvati's maternal authority
with Shiva's awareness. Through Ganesha,
their distinct energies found unity,
nurturing protection, merged with
complete consciousness, creating a
mediator who stands at the junction
between mortal and divine. This
threshold between these two realities on
deeper levels, Ganesha's beheading
represents the ego and the necessary
destruction of all of our earthly
desires. Created from Parvati's body, he
symbolizes
an individual selfhood. Shiva's violent
yet transformative intervention replaces
limited ego with wisdom. This divine
conscious wisdom signified by the
elephant head. True spiritual awakening
requires the ego death and the birth of
wisdom. Painful but essential in the
transformation from limited self to
divine consciousness. And as our journey
through Shiva's multifaceted nature
continues, we encounter one of the most
mysterious forms known as the Dakshin
Amirthi. This is the silent teacher.
Unlike most Hindu deities who face east,
Dakshin Amirthi uniquely faces south
symbolizing his role as a guru who
guides souls from ignorance towards
enlightenment. In this manifestation,
Shiva sits under a banyan tree which is
known as being youthful and serene
imparting wisdom to sages not through
speeches but through silence. And this
silence is an emptiness but it is a
fundamental presence. It is being
perfectly in touch with exactly what's
happening in the now. Direct
transmission of truth being more
important than words themselves. And
this scene again gives humans another
powerful insight. Authentic knowledge
doesn't come from outside. It comes from
within the human. And the Banyan tree
with roots reaching both skyward and
downward again becomes another important
Hindu symbol of wisdom bridging divine
and earthly realms. And this moment
teaches that real understanding isn't
taught. It's realized. It's not from
outside. It's from within. And in this
realization, this awakening is the
essence of spiritual life. As Mahay
yogi, the great hermit at top mount
klesh, Shiva demonstrates that
meditation isn't withdrawal from cosmic
responsibility. It is balance. It is a
balancing force that maintains universal
harmony. And in yogic traditions, he's
the atiguru, the first teacher from whom
all authentic paths of meditation and
inquiry and inner transformation then
flow. His discipline transcends denial,
embodying mastery, conquering the mind,
the ego, senses, everything to awaken a
higher awareness. And in Shiva, you
witness the ideal of perfect
self-control and radical inner freedom.
From ancient ashrams in India to modern
yoga studios worldwide, the teachings of
Shiva continue to inspire millions
seeking this transformation. I mean even
beyond the physical exercise that many
people in the west see yoga as it
actually embodies very much a spiritual
manifestation of Shiva's will. Shiva's
yoga was never just physical. He taught
that yoga is a complete path for body,
mind and soul. It emphasizes balance
between strength and surrender, effort,
ease. Again, this contradiction that
we've mentioned so many times. And
today's recognition of yoga as healing
and as sort of a mental wellness
exercise echoes the original vision.
Yoga meant to heal the whole person not
just to you know increase our
flexibility. So as we reach the end of
this journey we need to understand that
Shiva transcends the category of a
deity. He represents a state of
consciousness pure consciousness in and
of itself. An inner reality that is
accessible to all human beings to you
listening to this right now. the
profound awareness that exists within
all existence serving as you know as
source and also you know our ability to
subjectively understand experience. So
throughout his countless manifestations
you know the dancer, the silent teacher,
the protector, the loving spouse, the
meditating yogi, Shiva reveals that
consciousness itself contains all
possibilities. He appears as the
stillness beyond the motion, the silence
beneath the sound, the wisdom beyond the
words. His essence teaches us that
awakening isn't a destination, but this
dance between form and formless, between
individual self and the universal self.
And Shiva's mythology flows as wisdom
rather than ancient history. his dance
eternally between destruction, creation,
this meditation in cosmic solitude, but
yet you know embracing existence with
love throughout classical arts and
contemporary interpretation through
sacred architecture and spontaneous
devotion. He continues to reveal himself
as it's understood in Hindu philosophy,
not just as a deity but a mirror
reflecting your journey towards
awakening. When one understands Shiva in
Hindu tradition, it is hoped that you
can realize he's not something external
to worship from a distance like many
western theologies. But it is the very
awareness of being able to you know hear
this podcast or listen to this show or
you know the consciousness that's
experienced by all of us in this moment.
It is uh the witness of your thoughts,
the stillness between your breaths and
the love that connects all things. So
for many Hindus in you know a world
learn yearning for authenticity and
depth, Shiva exists as this you know
enduring example of more than just a
sacred symbol but is the eternal
invitation to become awakened or
enlightened. It's not just you know a
demanding belief but a direct experience
and the stories are not very dogmatic
but again point toward truth
transcending all all else. And the dance
continues as Hindus teach right you and
I are both the dancer and the witness.
We're both the seeker and what is sought
after. We're both human and internally
we are divine as Hindus teach. This
recognition not as a belief but as
experience is what Hindus consider
Shiva's ultimate gift. The teaching
in summary is pretty simple. Look deeply
into this moment into the present
awareness into the life that you're
already living. What you seek isn't
hidden in some distant realm or some
ancient book, but is dancing right here,
meditating right now and loving through
our very being, loving through our own
heart. And that is the wisdom of Shiva.
So if there's any Shivites that are
listening to this, any Hindus that
practice this type of meditation, I'd
love to know what you guys think. uh
this you know project of researching
shivism was really interesting to me
there's so many elements of Hindu
symbolism that I never understood right
you see uh you know Ganesha or you'd see
you know like Ganesha's elephant head or
uh you know the the dancing Shiva and
for me I never understood how deeply
spiritual and sacred so much of the
symbolism is and why it means so much to
Hindu people that have these symbols in
their home but now that I have an
understanding I kind of have more of an
appreciation for seeing you know Shiva
not as you know this evil villain a
satan if you will but rather a you know
a protector for many Hindu people so I'd
love to know what you guys think if
there's Hindus that are watching or
listening to this I'd love to know if I
missed anything please drop a comment
let me know if there's anything that I
got wrong and if you didn't grow up
Hindu or didn't know many Hindu people
growing up I would love to know what do
you guys think do you feel like this is
completely at odds with whatever your
personal spiritual philosophy is or did
you find anything from this you know
sort of analysis in Shiva to be helpful
or or even enlightening? I would love to
know. Please drop a comment. I will read
all of them whether it's on YouTube or
Spotify. And once again we will be in
this tent every single Sunday to explore
the most interesting, fascinating and
controversial stories from every
religion from around the world. And I
will see you next time. Peace be with
you. If you've made it to the end of
this episode, you are clearly someone
who understands that beneath every
historical event lies a deeper truth
waiting to be uncovered. You're the type
of person who knows that real history is
more fascinating than any fiction. And
we deeply appreciate that about you.
I'll be honest. That's exactly why I
personally invite you to sign up for
Today in History, our free newsletter
that goes beyond the surface of
historical events. We dive into the
stories that textbooks never told you,
the secrets that challenge the course of
nations, and the forgotten tales that
deserve to be remembered. Let's continue
this journey of discovery together. Take
the conversation from your headphones
into your inbox. Sign up now through the
QR code or link in the description today
in history because every day holds a
secret waiting to be revealed. Thank you
for being part of our historical
journey. We'll see you next time.